es el mayor incendio del año en la costa
azul francesa las llamas ya dejan un
desaparecido y un muerto en el municipio
deprimo aunque aún se investigan las
causas
además algunos sufren por intoxicaciones
y miles han sido evacuados entretanto
las autoridades se enfrentan a los
cambios de la dirección del viento y se
concentran en evitar que las llamas se
extiendan a nuevas zonas
lo que está claro es que las
perturbaciones climáticas harán más
lugar a incidentes de este tipo así que
si la temporada venciendo y forestal
empieza ahora tendremos que estar muy
defendidos o
un centenar de viviendas han sido
afectadas y se han perdido 5.000
hectáreas de bosque mientras tanto en
grecia a pesar de que la situación es
algo mejor el cuerpo de bomberos
continúa luchando contra un incendio
forestal al noroeste de atenas que
arrasó con unas 8.000 hectáreas en
italia los equipos de protección civil
tienen previsto terminar las labores de
contención de fuegos esta semana
mientras que en california las quemas no
sé
tenemos que hacer más y tenemos que
hacerlo mejor ya que tiene mucho que ver
con la gestión activa de nuestros
bosques nuestra vegetación y nuestro pre
posicionamiento de activos la intensidad
de estos incendios está creando su
propio clima persistente entre las
conflagraciones se han agudizado por los
vientos y han arrasado con la pequeña
ciudad de whisky flatts en el norte de
california una compañía eléctrica se vio
obligada a cortarle la luz a miles de
clientes